Hello, everyone.
Welcome to the Active Inference Lab.
This is the first active inference
model stream.
Active Inference Model Stream 1.0.
And I'm really excited
for today's conversation.
I'm Daniel Freedman and just to introduce
the other participants today.
Ryan Go for it.
Yeah.
Hi, I'm Ryan.
I'm from the Institute of Brain Research.
Hi, I'm Christopher.
I'm a Ph.D.
student at the MRC Cognition
Brain Sciences Unit, which is based
at the University of Cambridge.
Hi, I'm Max Murphy.
I just completed my Ph.D.
at University of Kansas in bioengineering
with Focus on Neural Engineering Awesome.
Thank you everyone for participating
and for Ryan and Christopher.
Two of the authors of this awesome work
we're going to be exploring.
So this is the first
in a several part series
that is going to be highlighting
several perspectives and addressing
questions
related to the active inference tutorial.
Paper of Smith et al.
Called a step
by step tutorial on active inference
and its applications to empirical data.
So the idea here is for those
who are working
with empirical data to learn about active
inference as a method.
And also for those
in the active inference community
to be learning about some of the methods
that apply active inference.
If you're
listening, you're participating.
And if you have any questions
during the live stream, feel
free to post it in the YouTube live chat
And we'll try to address it
during or after this presentation
that we're about to get.
If you have questions
after the live stream,
please feel free
to leave it in a comment form
and we'll try to address it and integrate
your input in future sessions.
And to learn more and to participate
check out Active
Inference North or any of the information
in the video's description.
So that's all the information
or metadata for this video.
The way this is going to work today
is we're going to do
some introductory questions,
just sort of like asking
what in general is this work about what
motivated the authors to write the paper
the way that they did?
And then both Ryan and Christopher
are going to share their screens
for part of the presentation.
And they're going to show us
a few different things
about the work that they've done.
And then we have a couple of questions
prepared on our side.
But also, we're going to be looking
at a live chat, if anyone has questions.
So just post it
whenever you feel like it
in the live chat,
and then we'll again try to address it.
So as I stated the intro questions
and then we'll go to the presentations.
So first intro question to the authors is
What is this work?
What is exciting about it?
What motivated you to work on it?
Okay, so.
So just to kind of reintroduce myself
a little bit more.
So I'm Ryan Smith, so I'm an investigator
at Lorain Institute
for Brain Research in Tulsa, Oklahoma.
And the focus of our institute
is primarily on
neuroimaging and sort of neuroscience
approaches to understanding psychology
and psychiatry with a focus on sort of
treating psychiatric disorders.
And so for a while now,
there has been the use of simpler
computational models,
primarily reinforcement learning models
or graph diffusion models.
Things like that
out there for researchers
for who are working with empirical data
who so there are good resources
out there for people
to learn those methods,
to apply them to data in their own
research.
However, at the moment, so active
inference is a sort of much newer field,
especially its sort of formulation
in terms
of partially observable
markup decision processes.
And there isn't really today
a really clear
sort of combined place
to learn the sort of practical methods
to to build these sorts of models
and to then sort of apply them
to task behavior in empirical studies.
And so the kind of motivation
for this paper or this tutorial
was to allow somebody,
you know, so new students or somebody
who is sort of like an early, early,
you know, junior faculty
things like that,
who wants to go in this direction
to give them the resources
they need to do that. And
as easily as, you know, in a store
early as possible.
So even if you start out not really
having any background in this stuff.
And the hope was that
you know, the first section of the paper
would allow you to kind of
get enough of a background in the theory
such that you would understand how to
then learn how to build these models
specifically for empirical tasks
and eventually
to learn
how to fit those models to the data
so that they could be used
in your own sort of research
even, you know, for across
many different fields.
So I would say what's what's exciting
or motivating is primarily just to that
if you're a new researcher
and you're interested in this,
but you don't know how to do it.
You know, the hope is
this is kind of going to be like a one
stop shop
where if you can get beginning to end
then you'll know how
to do what you need to do to start
using it in your own research.
So that's the major driving motivation.
Awesome.
I love that.
One stop shop for a researcher
who wants to apply the methods
but doesn't really know where to start.
So that's really a great idea.
And you have version the document many
times to really address people's input.
So it's cool
how it's an evolving document as well.
So Christopher, what would you say
in response to those intro questions?
Um, so I think there are two parts
of my motivation for writing this.
The first was a selfish motivation
in that I think if you want to understand
something, the best way to do
it is actually to write a tutorial on it.
And so in when Ryan asked me to do this
tutorial with him,
I was jumped at the opportunity
just because it would
be an opportunity to kind of
actually learn this stuff better myself
and really get into
some of the more technical details.
And so then more broadly
speaking, though,
I think there are lots
if in principle there's nothing kind of
applying these models and practices
no more complicated than doing like model
based reinforcement learning.
And yet it's incredibly more common
to see researchers
working with various
more sophisticated RL schemes.
And I think
if you are a graduate student, maybe
starting in psychology on neuroscience,
like, hey, I'm interested in whatever
it is, decision making under uncertainty.
And I mean, we have a finite time
in this earth, right?
And a finite amount of time to actually
dedicate into learning things.
And so I think
it would be perfectly rational
if someone to look at active inference
research
like, wow, this is super technical.
I wish I could learn it.
But here's this other thing
where I can go on your match.
I can read something in Bartow
and really totally get up to scratch
and use it my research fairly easily,
and it just wasn't something
really
accessible to help people actually
apply it in their own research.
So that was kind of my yeah, actually.
Yeah.
I mean, I should say,
just as a little background,
you know,
when I wanted to learn this stuff
originally at the end of my postdoc,
before I took my current
faculty position,
and I the only way to do it,
the only way that I could learn
it was actually to go, you know,
hang out at the cell in London
with Carl for about four months
and you know, just ask people
a ton of questions and sit there.
And that was the only way, you know, so
without having to physically go to
one location in the world,
I was very far away from,
you know, my current institution.
And without doing that,
there really was no way for me to do it.
So, I mean, it's sort of out of empathy
for my past self.
But, you know, this is a sort of thing
I wish I would have had available to me
so I could learn
this stuff independently.
Oh, so Max
what is your background or what
got you really excited to work
through the paper
and develop a lot of the examples
out on your own computer and everything
so what got you excited or
where are you coming from today?
Sure.
Yeah.
So maybe I'm kind of your target
demographic in some sense.
I don't know that I could really be
considered a junior investigator,
although I hope I could someday be that.
And I'm interested in
I'm much more on the motorcycle
motor system side of neuroscience
as opposed to the decision making.
So this just the whole lexicon,
it's a little different,
but I am seeing so many common
is when I'm coming
from a signal processing background,
I think of things in terms of calming
formulation and trying to integrate
sensory and motor information.
I see a lot of similarities there.
And so for somebody like myself, then
looking at some of the first ins work
and seeing how he's described, you know,
the anatomy of inference and could this
apply also in motor systems.
I'm very interested to
see how this might apply
in my own future research and work.
For So let's
just say that you were speaking
Ryan first and then Christopher
to that early investigator,
researcher of any age who is like, Okay,
I get it in reinforcement
learning, it's about reward or reward
centric learning is about reward.
What is active inference?
How is it taking a different perspective
on what it is that organisms are doing?
Then that kind of classical accounts
of reward based learning, for example,
or whatever
you'd like to contrast it with,
but what is the bridge
from the kind of assumptions
and implications that lead
somebody to work on that classical
framing versus
what is the difference in thinking
that is active inference
and how is that manifested in the model?
So I think
this is actually a really important thing
to bring up right from the start.
Is that so there's a
there's a kind of big distinction between
when people talk about the free energy
principle broadly or the philosophy
of the free energy principle
and is a very kind of
you know, somewhat wide chasm
between that
and what gets called active inference
nowadays, where active inference,
as a corollary of the free energy
principle, but
you know, active inference as formulated
in terms of partially observable,
partially observable markup decision
processes is quite a bit narrower.
Right?
It's a very specific sort of discrete
state space generative model,
and that has particular
sorts of elements to it.
And it doesn't actually
require knowing
a lot of the things that people talk
about with respect to the free energy
principle more broadly.
And it appeals to free
energy and expected
free energy as functions right as more or
less cost functions for figuring out
what the best choice to make is
and it but but at the end of the day,
I mean, when you apply
these sorts of models to behavioral tasks
like I used in studies
it's actually there's
quite a bit of similarity.
I mean, you can really see
active inference models
or at least the empty formulation
as, as just a
particular is kind of
like what Chris said is just a particular
kind of flavor almost of model based
reinforcement learning,
you know, so instead of
I mean, there's, there's some sort of
technical differences, right,
where the way that sort of Karl
and them have set it up
and what you're doing is kind of like
it allows for kind of a fully unified
Bayesian way
of doing reinforcement learning
and decision making processes.
And you do that
by instead of calling something a reward
or say you define this probability
distribution over observations
that gets
called a preference distribution
and so reward then becomes
a kind of probabilistic preference
to observe some things over others,
you know, so whether you call
a particular observation a reward,
then calling it a reward
just amounts to having a precise
preference distribution
that has a precise
high value over
whatever that rewarding outcome is.
And then the agent is simply driven
to make decisions that it thinks
is most likely to get it to observe
the thing it prefers.
Right.
So this preference distribution is more
or less a way of specifying
what is rewarding to the agent.
Right? What the agent is seeking
One thing that is kind of nice
about active inference
that's a little different
from reinforcement learning per se,
or there's a few things I should say.
One is that
making decisions based on
trying to minimize expected for energy,
which will cover,
doesn't just try to maximize reward.
It also simultaneously tries
to maximize information gain.
And so so what will happen is,
you know,
I say say an agent
starts out in a dark room, you know,
just to take a very kind of contentious,
you know, philosophy of the FP
sort of example, right?
Let's say
an agent starts out in a dark room,
which means that it doesn't know
where anything is.
Right?
So that means that has a lot of
uncertainty over what state it's in
unless they simultaneously
in another room,
there's a fridge with some food in it.
Then there will be two different
sorts of drives there, right?
There'll be this epistemic drive to
do whatever it thinks is going to give it
the most information gain.
Right.
Which will be a go
turn on the light, right?
So then it'll know what state
it's in Right.
Whether it's in room or room B, right.
Or whether there's a couch in the room
or whether there's a TV in
the room or whatever. Right.
And that's not reward per se.
That's just trying to make the app choose
the action
that's going to maximize
the amount of information you get.
The other the other chunk of it, though,
is to maximize
observing preferred outcomes.
And so the agent will also be driven
to just leave the room
to go to the fridge,
you know, to observe itself eating food,
you know.
So in practice, what will happen
that typically won't happen,
at least in a standard reinforcement
learning setting,
is that the agent won't
just try to maximize reward directly.
A lot of times
it will first choose the action
that will help it figure out where it is
so that it's more confident
what to do to get the reward later.
And so so it's
so it's really not again, in practice,
these models are are just a nice fully
Bayesian way to integrate
perception, learning and decision making,
where decision making is driven
to both maximize information
gain and maximize reward.
Christopher, thanks a lot.
Anything else to add there?
No, not particularly.
I think the only thing I would say
and I'm going to say
this in a little bit on slide is
if you're interested
in the technical details,
what Ron just said,
there are two really good papers.
Maybe you can make me slides
available afterwards as well.
One's by and also it.
And I'm not sure if I'm sorry
if I butchered your name.
The other one's Lancelot de Costa,
and they have two excellent papers
comparing it
to reinforcement
learning center formulations.
Excellent.
Just to draw out a couple points, Ryan,
from what you said.
So one is that the active inference
framework and specifically the PEO MDP,
the partially observable
Markov decision process, instantiate
ation of active inference is a corollary
or like a derivative of the free energy
principle.
And there's a lot of philosophy
and contentiousness
around different aspects of that.
We're going to read a paper in Active
Inference Stream 14 by Mel Andrews about
the math is not the territory,
about the philosophy and the status.
So yes, if you want to go that way,
there's a whole rabbit hole there.
But this is kind of like a tool,
like a linear regression.
You don't get caught up in the weeds
on number theory or on the information
space that it's about where
the calculation is useful and tractable.
It's going to be a tool.
So that's kind of where we're coming out,
at least today and in this series.
Another interesting thing,
and in contrast with reinforcement
learning,
which is kind of like reinforcement works
and don't reinforcement
doesn't work, that neurons
that fire together wired together
positive reinforcement schemes.
There
is a reward
preference built into that kind of model.
But when there's a basin of low reward,
it's often
difficult for those models to latch on.
So we saw that in the paper
of Alec Chance at all
in active Infinite Stream eight scaling
active inference that kind of showed
how even up against these very,
very large scale machine learning models
like cue reinforcement learning
and things like that,
other state of the art deep
learning models that the active inference
trolley, car and control theory
robots were able to work
really well because first they did what
you just described, Ryan, which was they
kind of went into an explorer mode before
going into a more fine tuning mode.
And so in doing so, they transcended
the explore exploit simple trade off.
It's not just a knob in this model, it's
not a coefficient to balance, explore
versus exploit,
I hope will draw out an understanding
that they're actually related
in a different way
because there's something that's model
based and generative that's happening.
And so really a ton of interesting stuff.
So at this point, I would think
we could go into the presentations
if people have any questions that arise,
put them in the YouTube chat,
and I'll be copying those out
for addressing them later.
And other than that, let's just work
through the presentations,
however Ryan and Christopher
have set up in.
Perfect. Cool. Okay. Go ahead.
And just very straight for us,
so you can just go ahead.
Yeah, it's going
Okay.
So I'm using a dual monitor set up.
We'll see how this goes.
Okay.
Sorry.
I now open system preferences.
Sorry to allow Microsoft teams to use it.
Sorry about that.
Okay.
Should be with you momentarily.
Cool.
Good to digest.
Really.
It's really it's interesting stuff,
and we're all learning by doing here.
So just really appreciate
and have just seen a lot of appreciation
for this kind of work because
in some ways, it's like the missing piece
between a lot of these hypothetical
or abstract or scaffold models
or what people have heard about
with respect to what active inference is
and then how it's deployed,
how it's enacted, so to take the
an activist insight
seriously as practitioners of science
and as communicators as well,
it means making this kind of work
and showing us how you do it
as we all are trying to figure out
every level,
from literally the tech to the best way
to make it rigorous and accessible,
the best ways to talk about it.
So, yeah, well,
what do you think about that? Right
Yeah.
I mean, I certainly agree.
Hold on to Chris.
Yeah, actually, I've never used
this, although.
There should be a little thing
in the upper right corner.
It's like an arrow pointing into it,
into like a square.
Share content.
You guys both on PCs?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
So, yeah, so it should be upper right
corner, like right
next to the leave button.
Okay.
Or Ryan, you could present first or.
Yeah.
I actually, I have a question.
For me to present first.
I think I think you're, you know.
Yeah, what I'm going to do, I'm not going
to be so comprehensible for Chris.
Got it.
I actually have a question
that will take a couple of minutes.
Christopher, what you're figuring out
is what tools
would somebody need to follow along?
So what programing, language
or what interface do they need?
What background knowledge do they need?
Is there a software to download?
Is there a course?
What are the prerequisites
for doing what?
We're about to basically jump into
Yeah.
So I mean, I'll just say that, that,
you know, a lot of this stuff
was originally designed by Carl Thurston.
And if you know a lot about Carl,
you know, before he proposed a lot
of the sort of inference stuff,
you know, he was sort of most
famous or his his biggest contribution
was putting together a ZPM within MATLAB.
SPM is like a it's called statistical
parametric mapping software.
But it was more or less
the original way of doing F MRI.
So like analyzing functional,
like neuroimaging data
and so a lot of the scripts
and dynamic puzzle modeling,
I should say, which is a particular
sort of approach to doing or imaging.
And so a lot of basically
all the standard resources,
all the standard coding routines,
everything for actually building
active inference models right now
is primarily an SPM,
which runs within MATLAB
and so and all the kind of supplementary
tutorial code that we've provided,
we provide I think 66 or seven different
different supplementary scripts
where you can actually run
the simulations
and build these models yourself.
They are
they are all they're all in MATLAB.
So if you, if you have MATLAB
and you need to have downloaded SPM
and with MATLAB in SPM, you
you will have everything you need to do
to open our supplementary code
and to and to follow along to a lot of
the tutorial is actually set up.
So it assumes that you kind of have
the paper open side by side with the code
so you can actually click on,
you know, different options
to simulate and reproduce all the figures
in the in the tutorial paper.
So it's yeah.
So the short answer is
you need MATLAB and you need SPM
things for
you to have some minimal ability to work
with with matlab.
Just to just to piggyback on to that
for anybody's
benefit watching this in the future,
whenever you're watching this,
once you get the spam folder,
you know, you'll unzip
that, you'll get that folder, you'll
put that somewhere on your computer.
You want to make sure that you add path
from your MATLAB workspace when you're
in the supplementary code provided
by Ryan and Christopher.
When you're in that workspace,
add path of that folder
wherever you put it, add path
of that folder slash toolbox slash DPM
and then you should have access
to the additional SPM.
12 scripts that you need in order to make
use of the functions they've provided.
Yeah. Yeah.
Thank you very much. I mean, that's that.
Yeah.
For someone who has never used MATLAB.
Yes, there's a few steps like that
which are super important.
Yeah.
Because basically all these scripts
are actually within. Yeah.
Within the toolbox
of SPM
and all the scripts they've provided.
Call on
sub functions
within that are within SPM
and so, so yeah, it won't unfortunately
none of them will work without without us
SPM at the moment,
although there are certainly efforts
to try to make
some of these routines
more sort of generally accessible and
like free software like alec electrons,
for example, is in the process of
I think writing a like
a Python version of the, of the main
act of inference MGP script,
which is called the,
it's called a
SPM underscore, MGP
underscore, VB underscore X
and that just correspond that just MDP
underscore, VB underscore x corresponds
to a markup decision process underscore
Variational Bayes underscore
X which stands for fact arised.
And I'll, I'll go over what factorization
is and how you actually code that end.
Once we get to my section
okay.
I'm going to ask a follow up there.
So I have my desktop computer,
I have MATLAB
and it's all working with referencing
SPM most updated version.
And I've run through the examples
that we're going
to be working through maybe today
or the ones that are in the paper.
So I kind of hit Enter
and I got things to work.
Everything's
all the scripts are working fine.
What information from my system
do I need to know?
Like what measurements are going to be
relevant for me to bring to the table
if I'm going to do a t test
for whether to and colonies
are a different size, you know,
I know what kind of machinery I'm
going to need, you know, two columns
in the Excel spreadsheet or something,
but what kind of data or what
attributes of the system
are important
to bring to the table for an investigator
to utilize the examples
that you're providing
and yes.
So I mean,
so I mean, there's a couple of things.
I mean, so so first the
you know, so the first goal is, you know,
you take a particular behavioral task
and you have to figure out
what the right generative model
is for that task.
And this is the sort of thing
that I'll give an example of.
I can actually show you
multiple examples of this.
And so once you have this
or generative model set up,
then you can run simulations
and those simulations will generate
observations and generate
expected actions.
And so so what you need then is you
need data
from an actual participant performing
that task
where you'll know on each trial what
the person observed, write what the task
stimuli were and you'll know what
action they actually chose.
And so
then what you'll do ultimately is
you'll do what's called
parameter estimation, which is and again,
this will be a lot more comprehensible
once I actually show you.
But basically what you try to do
is you try to find the set
of parameters values in the model
that generates behavior
that's most similar
to what the participant actually did
and so once you define the parameters,
you say one has a value of two
and the other has a value of four,
and that generates behavior
that's identical to whatever
a given participant did.
Then those values of two and four,
you can use those as individual
difference estimates,
you know,
so if you have those values
for a bunch of different people who
behaved in different ways on the task,
then you could say, hey, you know,
is there something different,
right, about the people
that have a parameter value of four
versus a parameter value of eight?
Right.
Can I use that to predict, for example,
you know, how well somebody is going
to respond to a particular treatment,
say, in computational psychiatry?
I curse twice. Yes.
It's an.
Yeah.
But so.
But so
but so that's that's kind of the idea.
And, you know, and I mean, I can
I can share my screen
in the meantime and I don't know.
Well, here I can
I can perhaps go through some of this.
So I'll just share my screen
until I'm good.
Yeah. Sorry.
That was this whole thing was.
Oh, you're good.
I think I am, at least.
Can you guys see my screen?
I it's perfect.
Right? Yeah. Okay, great.
Sorry about that.
There are some,
a whole bunch of privacy issues.
I had to cancel the passwords.
Passwords anyway. Okay, we are here.
So it's
okay.
So you guys saying my present of you,
are you saying the full thing.
Looks we see the we see the full site.
Yeah, just this little Okay,
so this is just kind of part one.
After I've done gone through this,
Ryan is going to take over and go through
some of the practical aspects of it.
And so then just kind of reiterate
the scope and purpose.
Our target
audience really is kind of researchers
in neuroscience and psychology
that don't have a strong kind
of quantitative background
in math or email and in particular,
early career researchers.
And we just really want to provide people
with the requisite background
to actually apply this in the context
during a search okay.
And then so just to quickly highlight
some really fantastic other resources,
the first papers by Lancelot to Costa,
which is an incredible
technical review, just came out
mathematical psychology.
No, it has a really other incredible
paper.
This came out in neural computation.
And I think the
comparison to dynamic programing, element
formulations is still in preprints if,
if that's right or wrong.
But as well,
there's some really phenomenal
informal tutorials
with Oh excellent Chuck,
I'm sorry if I put you your name,
but anyway, that fantastic
kind of informal tutorials on Medium
and then lastly is kind
of the closest thing to what we're doing
today is these lectures by
Philip Shorten
back in the computational psychiatry
some school.
And these really are fantastic.
The only difference is that they work
with, to my knowledge,
I think they work at the UN Factories
MDP scheme,
which is a little less flexible
than where working with IRC.
And so there are a lot of ways
of motivating active inference.
I think kind of the way
that's most intuitive towards people
in cognitive science or backgrounds
in cognitive science is to kind of stop
and aspect of the amazing brain.
And so interrupting
if anything is kind of moving
too quickly
or too slowly or anything like that.
But broadly speaking,
the idea is, is that the brain encodes
a generative model of the environment
where this generative model is just kind
of a joint probability distribution.
And then outside or in the outside world,
is it where there are states and observe
and states give rise to observations
and we use the generative model
in combination with Bayesian
updating to insert the hidden causes
of our sensations from the observations.
And then we take actions based upon
our kind of internal model of the world
that couples us back to the generative
process that is that makes sense.
And so there's this kind of perception
action, a loop that's always going on.
Across, I think I think you
might want to tell people
just what the peo karma pie is.
All right. Okay. Yeah. So okay.
So that is a joint probability
distribution over observations,
states and policies where policies
and just actions or sequences of actions
that are available
to kind of all of the actions
that are afforded
to the agents, essentially
okay.
And so then kind of just we start
with like a review to illustrate
this will just give like a really,
really basic example.
And so you might be imagine
being presented
with kind of a shadowy shape like this.
And then you might
and what you want to do is infer
the causes of that shape based
just based upon
the observations.
But you don't just have observations,
right?
You have some prior
knowledge about the world.
And so we can specify that here.
So we might say we are two possible
causes in this very limited example.
That is,
we might say that the shadow is caused
by convex surface or a concave surface,
and they have fairly similar
probabilities.
However, we also have the structural
prior that was kind of acquired
through a lifetime of experience
of just light emanating from above
and under kind of a structural PRI
that emanates from above
the likelihood of the observation
of that particular shadow
of conditional of being concave
is much, much higher
okay.
And so then we can then combine the two,
the prior and the likelihood
to give us a joint distribution
where this is just kind of conditional
on a specific observation
we can
and then with some over
the states in that likelihood
to give us our marginal likelihood
and then divide our joint distribution
or a generative model
by our model likelihood,
and that's called model inversion
or is often
colloquially called model innovation.
And from there
we get our posterior distribution.
This is the probability of states
conditional on observations.
And so we started with a prior
and the likelihood
and got to a posterior
through Bayes rule.
And that is kind of formally speaking
the optimal
way to infer
the probability of hidden causes
given observations.
And the complication to all this
is that the marginal likelihood
is generally speaking,
computationally intractable.
So in the case of these
very simple discrete distributions,
the number of sums
that you have to perform scales
exponentially
with the size of your hypothesis base.
That's extremely impractical
and kind of more realistically
when you're working with
in continuous databases,
if you have non Gaussian or nonlinear
signals there, just analytically,
the distributions is analytically
tractable.
So I think you think, Max,
that a question yeah. Yes.
I guess real quick, just just to really
explicitly touch on the idea of hidden
hidden states and hidden variables
in this particular context,
would it be fair to say
that it's not only the convexity
or concavity of the potential,
you know, thing that I'm looking at,
but also I could think of the light
source, the direction
from where the light source
is as being another hidden variable
and those things together.
Would it be fair to term those as under
my mark of blanket, or is that
getting a little too far out from where
we want to be talking right now?
Yeah.
So Markov Markov blankets don't really
the kind of mark a blanket concept here
doesn't really come in in
any really interesting way.
I mean, you can formulate it that way,
but really the idea is just
you have this prior expectation.
So when you're looking at the little gray
desk right there under observation,
most people when you look at it,
even though it's actually just
a flat shape with some, you know, it's
just a flat two dimensional thing
that has a little bit of darkness
in one place, a little bit of lightness
and another and you know, if
most people see that as being concave,
even though it's a flat 2D thing, right.
So the idea is, is just that
there's a reason, right?
Why people typically see it as
being concave is it's kind of like
popping in as opposed to out.
And that's specifically
because there's this prior belief that
that light
sources tend to come from above.
So the hidden states here are kind of
there is a joint in the likelihood,
which just means that there's a
in the upright where it says likelihood
there's a concave coma light from above.
Right.
So those are two different hidden states.
And what it's saying is
if the hidden states are concave
and light from above,
if the combination of those things
is what's generating
the what I'm
seeing with that gray disk thing
and the probability of the shadow shape
of the shadow pattern
that you see is 0.9,
whereas if it was convex
and light from above,
if those were the two hidden states,
then the probability
you get that same that same shadow
pattern is only point one, right.
In other words, it'd be really hard
to get that pattern of shading
if if the thing was popping out
under the assumption
that where it's coming from above.
So so
the observation here is shadow
and the hidden states are concave and
light from a concave or convex and light
from above and light from below.
Okay. Thanks.
Yeah. Just one other quick example.
There would be like the chessboard
with a shadow and a dark square.
It's perceived
under a deep cultural prior.
That chessboard is
a regular alternating grids.
It makes an ambiguous,
shaded square appearance, something
that's quite different than it
is. People can look that up.
And then another thing this reminds me of
is like using a T test to test
whether a group, a versus B is taller
or something like that, it assumes.
But it could be an assumption
that could be slightly bent.
Is it assumed that other
than the variable being considered
other things are sort of fixed
or not mattering?
Otherwise, your statistical test
is basically misleading
because it could be capturing some
totally confounding variable
in the framework you put it in.
And so whenever you're talking
about a real biological organism,
you're talking
about conditioning on certain things,
and then given what is
totally conditioned out of the picture.
So I kind of see
where you're going with the blanket,
but it's not specifically in this place.
But good question.
But it's like depending on the
irrelevancies that we can condition out,
then we're looking at the conditional
relationships between different
observed states versus the hidden things.
So cool stuff.
And again, in the live chat,
people can post any questions on it.
Continue, Christopher.
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah. Thanks for covering that. Right.
Um, okay, so then the idea
is, is that the margin of likelihood
is generally computationally intractable.
That kind
of barring some ideas
from statistical physics,
what you can do is actually use
some approximation techniques.
And instead of evaluating the margin
of likelihood directly,
we can evaluate something
that is always provably greater
than or equal to the margin of likelihood
and simply come through that right now.
Okay.
And so we're just going to take the logs
kind of for mathematical convenience.
The reason we always work with logs
or generally speaking, is because log
log algebra is just a lot easier
just because it turns
multiplication ones into arithmetic.
So things, it's just easier to work
with essentially.
So we'll take the negative logs
of our marginal likelihood.
This is also sometimes called
Bayesian model evidence.
And when we have a negative log
of the probability, it's also called
surprise and information theory,
which is kind of the terminology.
I'm going to use
the rest of this presentation
And so you can see on the right hand
side of the equality, this is kind of to
some rule of probability we can get back
our surprised by the summing over
kind of all of the states under our joint
distribution over states and outcomes.
And then we can
kind of do a little bit of a trick here.
So I'm going to do now or show you is
that we are going to multiply this joint
distribution or generative model
by some arbitrary distribution.
We multiply and divide
by the same distribution
and so nothing has changed here.
This quality still holds.
I could cancel this if we wanted to,
but I don't want to.
And that's in particular
because I want to take advantage
of something called Jensen's inequality,
and that is that's a result showing
at the expectation of a logarithm
is always
less than or equal
to the logarithm of an expectation.
And so the idea is, is that this sum here
where the logarithm is inside
this summation we're sorry.
So we're taking with summing over
this kind of difference
between a generative model
and this approximate target distribution
when the logarithm is inside
that it is always going to be
and we're in kind of negative territory,
it's always going to be greater
than this quantity on the left hand side
where this left hand quantity is equal
to surprise because the log is outside
the sum, we can cancel these
kind of approximate distributions right.
And end up back at surprise.
On the right hand side, we can't do that.
This right hand side will only be equal
to surprise when our generative
distribution perfectly matches
our approximate distribution.
And so this quantity
on the right hand side here,
this is variational free energy
and so the idea is,
is that we find the probability
distribution,
this approximate probability
distribution, which we make simplifying
assumptions about and so we can kind of
evaluate analytically,
we make simplifying, we
find the value of this distribution
that best minimizes F
where F is variational free energy
is that kind of makes sense.
Hey, Chris, just one thing.
Are you like trying to like move
your mouse around to point to things? No.
I'm I'm actually holding my mouse.
I'm scribbling my mouse
a little bit on the live stream.
They should be able to see that.
But Christopher
thank you for that really awesome example
because it really clarified a few things.
Any other notes to add here?
Otherwise, this is cool to continue
yeah.
Okay.
So then just kind of
to give a really toy example of this
so we can get to find
our approximate posterior.
I'm kind of arbitrarily is a flat
distribution will have a true posterior.
Generally speaking,
we don't know what this is,
but the illustration site
we're going to give give it to you
and then we can have a joint distribution
and then observation.
What the observation will do is it's
just going to select a kind of a column
from this joint distribution
and so then we have
we can have into this into the equation
we saw on the last slide
and we'll slowly but
surely in each update nudge
our posterior distribution
such that it minimizes F on each step.
And at the third step,
you see, what we should say is that
when F is at a minimum,
it is equal to surprise.
And when F is at a minimum
as well, it's at a minimum because
the true posterior
and our approximate posterior match.
So that kind kind of makes sense.
And so the idea is, is that by performing
Bayesian inference and having and kind
of forcing some arbitrary distribution
to approximate our posterior,
we come up with an upper
bound on surprise
or we come to an upper bound on surprise.
Let me kind of just walk through
and just double check here.
So CU of S is our
estimate of whether the coin is a fair
coin.
50 50 means that it's 50 50 and then 80.
20 is the reality on the table,
so to speak.
So it's almost like first
we click from 50 50, we see heads come up
and that contributes a little bit of
evidence that maybe heads is more likely.
So we go from 50 50 to 60 40
and then something happens again
and we click on the second update
to 7.7.3,
we click eventually it's a .8.2.
And then if we click all the way to 0.9.1
so a 90 ten, all of a sudden
we go back up from point
six, nine, three, back up.
So if we were to plot this final
estimated F we'd find that we were like
going downhill, getting better, get 2.693
in this discrete 0.1 movement space
and then we pop up a little bit too far,
we overshoot
and we get a little bit more surprised
by the distributions that we're drawing.
Yeah, exactly. That's perfect.
Well, the only,
the only thing that I would say that's
I mean, a little different just to note,
is that there's nothing in this example
where you observe something
over and over again.
Yeah.
This is,
this is just a single observation once.
And you're trying to figure out what
what is the you're trying to figure out
what the true posterior is trying to get
as close to it as possible.
Still, you're doing is saying, here's
the single observation,
but I'm going to try out
a bunch of different values for cues.
So I try different values
for that approximate distribution.
And I'm just going to find the one,
you know, through this kind of iterative
updating thing where I slowly move cues,
you know, to different values
you just do that for a single observation
and you can update until you find
the minimum free energy value,
which just tells you
that you're approximate posterior
the QC thing is as close
as really close to the true posterior
that you couldn't figure out on your own
because the problem was too tough
to solve with exact Bayesian inference
So this this is kind of corresponds
to what people might talk about
as prediction error minimization, right?
So you just see this observation once
and the brain tries to minimize
prediction error by minimizing F
by just moving beliefs
until it finds the the belief
that minimizes F, which is the same thing
as minimizing prediction error
like that is that makes sense.
Let me clarify, because I think
that really helped me understand it.
And at first I thought,
wait with one observation,
because at first when I described it,
I was thinking update was tied
to a new observation from the coin.
But then I thought, well,
if you're only getting one observation,
the maximum likelihood model is a coin
that only comes up heads
because you only have one observation,
but it's not one shot
parameter learning naive.
It's actually a tethered estimate
that's tethered even loosely, but nonzero
tethering to a prior point, 5.5.
Some people will say uninformative,
but all priors are informative
they're all what they are.
And then it's
almost like because of the logs,
even though you only observed the coin
come up once, it's like,
All right,
it's a little too far to update to 90 91.
Just from seeing one coin flip.
I would need extraordinary evidence
for extraordinary updates.
And so it's like that one heads
observation updates you from 50 50 to
near 80 20, which does happen to be close
to the actual probability of the coin.
And it also happens to navigate this
explore exploit in an interesting way
because it updates it,
but not all the way.
So it's just kind of showing
how the Bayesian updating brings
some of that wisdom of multi observation
learning
like slow updating of parameters
and sequential updating
to a little bit of a different context.
So I mean I do
want to clarify here a little bit.
I mean there's, there's no actions here
so there can't really be explore exploit,
right.
You can't
we can't choose to look over here versus
over there to gain information, right?
So explore exploit is, you know,
specifically in the realm of make it
choosing actions that will minimize
uncertainty versus maximize reward.
And this is this is really more adjust
with with normal free energy right.
We're not expect expected for energy yet
which is the making part
with normal for energy.
There's you can think the simplest way
to think about free energy
is just in terms
of complexity minus accuracy,
which is
equivalently complexity
plus prediction error
and all that all that ultimately means is
so the complexity thing is
basically
how much you have to change your beliefs.
So it's basically saying,
what's the minimum change in my beliefs?
That will make my new beliefs
as accurate as possible?
Right.
So I have to move my beliefs
as little as possible
while also minimizing prediction error
if that if that makes sense.
So this what this generative
model is saying is just that
the probability that we're in state
one is 0.8
if I were to choose
if if I were to get this observation
where the probability of being in state
two is only point to
where I to get this observation right
so so I mean, the probably
a better example than the than the like
heads and tails thing would just be
would just be something like the concave
convex example we gave before inside.
There is some possibility
where we're light from above,
where a light from below
could cause the shading pattern,
but it's just much less likely.
Right.
So you're just trying to find the,
the belief, right,
that it's convex and light from above,
that that is the one that most likely
generated what you're what you're seeing.
And it might take a bunch of updates
like that given just what you see wants
to kind of arrive
at the best fitting belief.
There's a related question in the live
chat that I'm just going to ask
because it's on the topic.
They asked,
is this approximate Bayesian inference
thing called something else in stats
outside of active inference,
or is this unique to active inference
because this isn't sequential
Bayesian updating, as you mentioned,
this isn't a standard Bayesian filter.
What is this called
outside of the active inference field?
So yeah, it's just Variational Bayes.
Variational, Bayes.
Where does the partially observable
Markov decision process come into play?
We'll cover that in a moment's
time, actually.
It does. It does, yeah.
It doesn't come in yet.
So I think one thing to say
is kind of writing this tutorial,
it's hard to please everyone right?
Like in going through
some of the feedback, like we get
we got some feedback
where people were just utterly confused
and wanting clear explanations.
And then at the other end of
the spectrum, we wanted
there were people wanting
much more technical details,
like how does this relate to things
like gradient descent?
Because this is just kind of
a very simplified cartoon
example of something called grading
as a great intercept scheme
where you're doing
a gradient descent on free energy.
And so I would just say kind of to flag
all of these issues is one,
I would say if something's unclear
in this presentation, read the paper
because we gave things,
we cover things
in a lot more detail in the paper.
And if that isn't technical, enough for
you as you go and just look at our code,
we supply a kind of standalone script
where we it's extreme
and it's extremely well commented.
And from there you should be able
to figure out everything that's going on
So all of this stuff in this presentation
is kind of necessarily simplified
because you don't really need
those technical details to kind of start
using the framework or start
getting intuition for how things work.
But once you do have an intuition,
you want more, just go and see the code.
I would say.
Awesome.
It's like you can use the ANOVA package
in or without going into the source code.
It's helpful. It's a tool for scientists.
And then if you're curious
about the underpinnings of statistics
and perennial philosophical debates,
there's a literature and a search bar,
but today it's about the applications
of these methods which is awesome.
So thanks to everyone for the questions.
Keep them coming.
But this is great
discussion. I really appreciate it.
Okay.
And so just kind of to recap there,
I haven't covered action yet.
I'm going to kind of action a little bit.
But just kind of to recap,
the idea is, is undirected inference
organisms are kind of we model them as is
the phenotype is in their body
and their brain kind of embodies
a generative model of the environment
and organisms kind of in
the general model to give an approximate
posterior distribution
over the hidden causes of sensory input.
And they do this
by minimizing variational free energy.
So that should that much
should hopefully be clear by this point.
And so then onto the generative model
and it is a very specific type
of generative model,
namely it's a partially observable
mark of decision process
and so that's kind of
a graphical representation of this
as a Bayesian network
on the right hand side.
And I'm not going to kind of give it
kind of give
too much detail about this right now.
I will actually build it up step by step,
but just kind of prelude.
The idea with Peter Pace
is that they described
transitions
among hidden unobservable variables
and the sensory data that's generated
by the variables loops. So
those arrows mapping from states
to observations are kind of gives
information about the direction
of influence or conditional in the
conditional influence.
So kind of the arrow
between the purple node.
Oh, and the green node s
is mediated by the matrix
which is a likelihood.
And the transitions
between states are mediated
by a B matrix,
which is a transition probability.
And so the goal of active inference
with power on deep is
is to infer states and action sequences
or policies
by minimizing various forms
of variational free energy
Okay.
So let's start with a really,
really simple example.
We have static inference
and the idea with static inference
is this
this is just a graphical representation
of his rule.
Essentially, we have a prior
which is encoded in our day vector.
We have a likelihood encoded in our
A matrix
and we end up with an update equation,
which is a soft max function.
A soft max function is a normalized
exponential. What's
and so I'm not going to kind of run
through that explanation in detail.
I'm just going to leave the slide here
so we can figure it out for themselves
and pause and go back
and convinced themselves
that this is true.
But it's a very simple example
of the inference scheme that we're using
here is formally equivalent.
It's just an exact inference scheme.
So moving into dynamic models
specifically, so where states
change over time, these are also called
hidden Markov models.
This is when we have to stop
making approximate
or when things are no longer
equivalent to a
using active inference.
I no longer equivalent to
exact inference
and so here
we have our transition
probabilities encoded in a B matrix.
And this is just essentially like
the probability of some state of T plus
one conditioned on the previous state.
And so you can see over here in times
the update equations
we're now in, we're in log space
and this little sigma thing here
is a soft max function
which just normalizes this equation.
And the idea is, is that this is kind of
sorry, my screen keeps flipping.
Anyway,
the combination
of D and base are two priors in addition
to our likelihoods
will give us the approximate posterior.
And the reason we have this one half in
front is just because in practice,
the approximation scheme
that's used by active inference, namely
variation on message passing, tends
to overestimate
kind of the value of the posterior.
And so this is kind of
just a way of compensating for that.
And so anyone's kind of interested
in technical details there.
See, Thomas Pyle has a really excellent
paper out in scientific reports
on your message passing schemes
on the various approximations
to free energy.
Okay.
And so then the form of the free energy
is just down here and so the idea is,
is that by iteratively applying
these updates, we minimize free energy
and you iteratively kind of every upstart
you do a full round of updating
every time you get a new observation
or that policy selection.
So the idea with policy
selection is roughly speaking,
that policies are just state transitions
that the agent has control over.
So imagine
you are a psycho physics experimenter
and you have just a very simple boring
example of someone kind of
say, estimating the orientation
of some hard to say stimulus.
And so the policy space
there is tiny it's two options of left
or right, let's say.
Or you could have an agent
that you could be simulating something
more interesting psycho physics.
You could be simulating an agent
navigating a maze.
And then the policy space is much larger.
They could go forward,
they could move forwards,
backwards, left, right, etc., etc.
And so
the idea is, is that active front
agents, by definition,
they dislike policies that will minimize
variational free energy,
but that relies
upon observations that have yet to come.
So that's kind of the problem.
But the way around
this is to treat observations
as random variables and then what you do
is you minimize an approximation
not to surprise, which is variational
for energy, but you expected surprise
and that approximation to expected
surprise as
is expected for energy.
And so this expected for energy
has two key components.
The first is the expected cost.
And this kind of minimize.
The idea here is you
minimize expected cost.
You need to minimize the deviation
between our predicted
and preferred outcomes.
And so this is kind of what we're talking
about running a spectrum before.
So we see vector encodes a distribution
over an agent's preferences.
So for example, policies
that minimize expected cost policies
that kind of bring about observations
that the agent prefers, for example.
So if I prefer to kind of have my body
temperature within a certain range,
the policy would be maybe staying inside
because I live in England and it's like
-1 outside,
for example.
Now expected ambiguity is a little bit
that this
this is kind of the epistemic drive
or the information gain term.
This is kind of the expected entropy
of our likelihood distribution.
So the idea here is,
is that to minimize ambiguity,
you'll have an A matrix, right?
And a matrix if the idea is to minimize
kind of ambiguity,
you need to select observations
in a matrix
that are maximally precise.
And so to return to or take actions even
that will make those things
that a matrix maximally precise.
And so if I'm in a dark room
to give an example for the thing
that will make or select kind of
policies that will make that distribution
maximally precise policies
like turning the light on.
And so then to minimize fringe
as a whole, you have to minimize
both of these things.
And you can do this in terms one step
policies, just looking one step ahead.
All you can do is look in using date
policies looking many, many steps ahead.
And hopefully that's pretty clear.
Is anything you'd like to add to that,
Ryan or Daniel?
Anyone else?
Yeah, I mean, I guess
I'll I guess I'll just say,
I mean, to
just to make it kind of as clear
and explicit as possible for people
who don't have a background in, you know,
what this whole thing,
you know, what this equation means.
Right.
So the idea is just if you look at that
term above expected cost
and that's called a cal divergence.
And so basically it's just a value
that encodes the difference between
two distributions or the dissimilarity
between two distributions.
And so that first one that Q given
PI, that's just saying
what observations do I expect
given that I choose to do this
versus that?
And then that second one,
that P of all, that's the preferences
so basically
what it's trying to do is just minimize
the difference between your
your preferred observations
and the observations that you expect,
given that you choose to do,
you know, thing one versus thing two.
So it's really just choosing the thing
that's going to get you as close to the
you think is going to get you as close
to what you want as possible.
So it's very just,
you know, reward seeking more or less.
And that second one,
the expected ambiguity that each thing
stands for entropy.
And basically entropy is just
the higher the entropy, the flatter
a distribution is.
So think of a distribution
that's like one is like 0.5.5,
and the other one's like .8.2.
If you chose the state, that would
generate 8.5.5 over observations
that wouldn't tell you anything
because either observation, you got it.
Tell you there's a 0.5 probability
that you're in one state,
in the probability
you're in the other state.
Right.
Whereas the other state would generate
a point eight or a point two.
Then that one will give you a lot
more information because you observe
if you observe the thing
that indicates 0.8
then you're really confident
what state you're in.
And if or if you observe point
two, you're really confident
you're not in that state, right?
So you're just seeking out
the thing that you think
will get you what you want
as much as possible.
But also moving to the states
that are going to give you
the observation that's going to tell you
the most about where you are,
if that if that if that makes sense.
So just again, just for people who
who aren't necessarily familiar
with reading the kind of notation
in these equations.
Thank you, Max.
Yeah.
I just want one point of clarification.
And then I just wanted to tie
it back to what
the example we had discussed previously.
So first, I want to just make sure
I'm understanding correctly that the D in
that equation is the k l diverge.
So that's the that's an operator it's not
the same as the D that's in the figure
in the block diagram.
That's that's the L divergence.
That's a yeah.
That's kind of a standard
way of representing yet another paper is
that's just kind of pasted in, but
it's not very clear that should be
the K l has nothing to do with d.
D sub. Fail.
The D d that's in this graphic
in the block diagram.
Would that be analogous in our previous
example where we were talking when,
when we illustrated step by step,
that would be R 0.5, 0.5.
But it in this context
could be much more complicated than that.
Yeah.
And a simple example.
Yeah, it would just be your prior. Right.
So if ahead of time you think that like
ice cream
is more likely than donuts, right?
Then that could just be like point eight,
point two,
you know, that's
or if you have no idea whether it's
going to be ice cream or donuts,
it could be .5.5.
In for it.
And for anyone who is like
wanting to get into optimization
and how do we know whether or not
this is going to converge
when we do our message passage or message
passing algorithm back and forth?
There was a really good citation,
and that's the one
that was alluded to at the beginning
of this on the slides.
Right.
The technical papers. Is that correct?
So the citation to do with message
passing in particular is a paper
by Thomas Parr
so that in scientific reports,
yeah, we can
I think you have showing notes.
I assume we can. Yes, please.
I have a couple other general questions
from the live chat,
but I think we'll take them at the end
of your presentation as we turn towards
some of the neurobiology beginnings
and a few other aspects.
So continue. Christopher.
Yeah, thank you.
Okay.
And so then kind of just to close
or just to briefly recap,
so there are multiple stages
to this to policy selection.
So under a generative model
that has multiple policies,
you need to minimize you minimize your
free energy with respect to each policy,
your variational free energy and
so you might think about this as you say,
you're coming to a set of traffic lights
and you have a hold up.
You could turn left, right or go straight
ahead.
Those actions are possible
but you then get sensory
input
that says there's another left hand side.
So that would make that policy
given extremely high for energy value.
And so that would eliminate it
from the plausible policies that you can
kind of evaluate. Right.
And so
then expected and fringe
is what we just talked about
and the posterior distribution
is actually
the soft max function over both of these.
And so this because kind of this is
these are both negatives
policies that best minimize
both variational for energy
and expected free energy
will have the highest posterior value
and then kind of it is
that is that clear?
There are a couple of caveats
to all of this, but
this wanting to make sure.
Right and you're allowed to thing here.
Well, I just say just just so anybody
who doesn't know like what a
what a soft max function is.
Yeah.
So so all that all that means
is that like for instance, when you take
minus F, minus G
and that's
not going to give you something that's
a true probability distribution, right?
It's not going to be a thing
that sums to one. Right.
We're probabilities altogether. Some 21.
What it's going to do
is give you this negative, you know, a
bunch of negative numbers, right?
So the soft max function does is it
normalizes that,
which just means that it takes
the kind of relative values,
you know, of each of those things
and turns it into
a probability distribution
that sums to one.
So so you end up with that bolded
PI symbol
is just a probability distribution.
That's assigned a product that assigns
a probability to each possible policy.
And a
policy, by
the way, is just a sequence of actions.
Right.
So one policy might be like
turn left, turn right, and another policy
might be turn right, turn left.
And so it's just saying that
and but that minus F minus thing
will just be turned
into a probability distribution.
And that probability distribution
over different policies
is what the agent will sample from right.
So if the if PI says this policy is point
eight, this other policy is point two,
then the agent will be a lot more likely
to choose the policy at this point.
Yeah.
Maybe go to the last caveat slider
then I have a few other questions.
Well,
we'll just try to like have a question.
Simple answer, question, simple answer,
and then we'll move into
the part to screen. Sure.
Okay.
So the two caveats are just I there are
two extra components of the MVP that is.